[музика]
це крилата ракета Таурус
шведсько-німецького виробництва Вона
може вражати цілі на відстані до 500 км
у Німеччині на озброєнні 600 таких ракет
і вони б знадобилися Україні
Київ а також українські активісти які
живуть в Німеччині наполегливо просять у
Берліна про поставки
такіми ракетами саме таврусом можна
сіяти по штабам а російських тронів і
російських ракет і таким чином знищувати
і забезпечувати безпеку українським
родинам дітям людям на етапі того як
производяться ці російські ракети і
дрони саме далекобійність цих ракет їхня
головна перевага і та причина з якою
Німеччина зволікає з їхньою передачею
Україні
Великобританія Та Франція вже постачають
Києву крилаті ракети але радіус дії
Таурус майже вдвічі більший
країни НАТО домовилися про те що не
можна допустити втягування Альянсу в цей
конфлікт і Вашингтон і Берлін надають
цьому особливого значення і тому
ключовий момент тут далекобійністю
зброїнь які ми поставляємо і за
допомогою яких можна запропонувати цілі
які не пов'язані безпосередньо з
військовими діями в Україні
до того ж Німеччина не хоче діяти
самотужки у минулому німецька Влада
завжди погоджувала свої поставки з
партнерами по коаліції насамперед із США
а Вашингтон поки що теж не планує
передавати Україні крилаті ракети
міністр оборони Німеччини Борис
пісторіус налаштований скептично за його
словами крилаті ракети зараз не в
пріоритеті штраф цімерман яка очолює
оборонний комітет німецького бундестагу
вважає що вже час дати зелене світло
передачі Україні далекобійних ракет
таороз за її словами цьому перешкоджають
у відомстві канцлера
тим часом повільність уряду критикує
опозиція передати Україні Таурус
закликав депутат бундестагу від хдс
родерів кіза ветер
Ukraine
Україна в ситуації коли діяти треба
негайно міжнародні союзники які
підтримують Україну мають діяти про
активну тому що масові жертви українців
справді жахливі й українському народу
потрібні перспективи однією з таких
перспектив є звільнення Криму шляхом
перерізання комунікації усіх ланцюгів
постачання з Росією
для того щоб відрізати шляхи постачання
озброєнь через Крим і потрібні
далекобійні ракети Таурус переконаний
депутат
він також наполягає що про можливу
ескалацію через використання ракет для
вражання цілей на території Росії не
може йти мови і що це не має завадити
Німеччині передати ракети Україні
єдина сторона яка йде на ескалацію це
агресор і це Росія росіяни могли б
негайно зупинити війну на всі кроки
заспокоєні ситуації з нашого боку
зволікання з рішенням щодо артилерії
зволікання з рішенням щодо БМП і танків
Росія відповіла новими звірствами та
жахливими діями
є лише одне обмеження не воювати проти
цивільних цілей в Росії Україна легко
може дотриматися цього Тому нам потрібно
протидіяти ескалації та зупинити
російське домінування
цього тижня до критики уряду приєдналася
і низка політиків соціал-демократичної
партії Німеччини що входить до коаліції
якщо уважно послухати Бориса в історію
що він не проти постачання просто вважає
що ще час не настав але я іншої думки
звичайно для нашої країни постачати
зброю в зону конфлікту це зміна
парадигми це нелегко це непросте рішення
але якщо подивитися на останні місяці Ми
звичайно думали надто довго над
прийняттям того чи іншого рішення і в
результаті воно все одно було прийнято
спільно з нашими партнерами і озброєння
було поставлено
Андреа Шварц сподівається що цього разу
дискусія так довго не затягнеться на це
розраховують і в Україні а активісти
віче за допомогою медіа-кампанії у
соцмережах закликають німецький уряд
діяти якнайшвидше і готуються виходити
на мітинг
Ми не можемо чекати на дуже
довгі розмови з приводу поставки зброї з
приводу поставки табрусу тому що кожна
хвилину коли в німецькому уряді люди
сумніваються в тому щоб надати ці
поставки в Україні ще один раз потім ще
один раз не справляється і ось той
випадок який в якому вона не
справляється ми всі бачимо в меді поки
німецький Уряд не наважується поставити
Україні крилаті ракети цього тижня стало
відомо про відправлення 25 танків
леопард 1 придбаних консервному райн
метал у бельгійської компанії та двох
зрк петріот
[музика]